you tell our life okay we are live hello
everybody
welcome to mit
and uh salt lake city so
i'm chris
and my colleague upstairs in the same
building as me simone just below me and
then
greg
in salt lake city hi
so today we're going to be talking about
um
a ocean model called oceananigans.jl and
this is work with a whole bunch of
people today we've got myself greg and
simone presenting
and we've also got a bunch of people on
the kind of q a monitoring responses
francis tamara suyesh rodrigo and
jean-michel probably we're not sure
exactly who's there but we'll someone is
there
um and the goal of today is really to
look inside this ocean model
um
i'm just getting a message that says
we're having trouble just streaming to
twitch uh so
i'm just gonna ignore that message
yes sorry twitch users um and the goal
of this session is really to uh dissect
so
who remembers i don't know who which of
you out there dissected frogs in school
but we're going to dissect our ocean
model so that's what this little uh
cartoon on the right
that sounds crazy is that right okay i
don't know i i i'm so old
did you did you do that
wow
okay so let's a lot of drug sacrifice in
the name of science oh shenanigans no
animals were harmed in that exactly
australians doesn't harm frogs
okay so the workshop goals are some
hands-on experience with ocean any guns
as an ocean model we're going to show
some illustrative numerical examples
the
ticker on the bottom of the screen and
you can also ask on uh
pigeonhole if you can't find
uh where to go but the ticker on the
bottom of the screen shows where the
code examples are and also has a link to
the actual raw code of oceanic and so
we're hoping that people will as we talk
we'll also be looking at the code
getting a bit familiar but we're going
to work through more examples there yeah
two
long examples to show you how things
sort of fit together um these are all
things that you can run yourself in
julia 1.6
they mostly run in 1.7 except apparently
on m1 max there's some issues with that
with 1.7
the examples can run in the repel or in
notebooks and
you can also run them in google colab
and there's a link on the slides that uh
and you can ask about that link in um
uh pigeonhole as well because i'm just
realizing you can't click on that link
um
that shows you in co lab you have to add
a little bit of extra julia but collab
lets you actually just run some stuff
you know in the cloud for free um and
we'll show you that gpus are faster than
cpus for some of the modeling stuff we
do so after the hands-on stuff we're
going to look at some of the inner
workings of the code so we're going to
try and show
how we're using julia to express our
ocean model some of the extractions we
found really nice in the judo language
to support the sort of numerical and
computational workflows we have around
sort of finite volume uh fluid dynamics
and then if there's time we're going to
try and fit in a learning parameters
example where actually
you know
there's no point in having a model these
days if you can't train it automatically
we don't want to do all that parameter
tuning ourselves by hand anymore so we
might try and get to showing how to
automate
finding the optimum parameters for a
particular ocean model problem
so
roughly we're going to spend about 15
minutes kind of just introducing ocean
modeling
then about an hour we'll see how it goes
on the simulation examples we have two
of them one is a non-hydrostatic
idealized process model the other is a
planetary scale ocean model
then about another hour or so in some uh
code dive and
looking at the language and how we use
it um
and then depending on time you know
getting to the learning example and then
towards the end we'll have just general
discussion through pigeonhole if we can
as we go we're going to leap to
pigeonhole periodically to check
questions and try and
answer them so feel free to throw
questions in there and we've already got
one question there you go i'll go and
we'll have a look in a second so i i
tried to answer it okay good uh but yeah
pigeonhole is the way to interact with
us as we talk uh we are julia sixx
uh for this session
and um at least for me uh
things all the tools we have work well
in chrome not so not always quite as
well in firefox and safari so
uh if you don't have chrome maybe you
need to install that at some point um
and yeah go to
livejunior.com.org obviously to see the
live stream you wouldn't know that if
you weren't watching the live stream so
you probably know that already
okay let's
go and just check out what's happening
in pigeonhole before we delve in
okay
how can i view the output of the
first model in the repo so the first
model in the repo is
i forget i think if you're talking about
the julia com 2022 rebel
then
um
and if by output you mean the plot
oh
yep can you hear me if my yeah yeah
we'll continue yep okay yeah then i
think typing display
display fig will
that will display the figure in your on
your screen if that's what's being
referred to the data is saved in a dot
jld2 file but anyways
so that's if you're running in the rebel
yeah you kind of do that yeah is that
you're saying correct yeah yeah i don't
maybe there's a different example that's
being referred to i'm not sure yeah if
you if you if if it's the gp ocean
example then there's no output at the
moment so i'm going to go through that
later
and i'll show you
okay
okay
so let's go back so with that
and we'll come back to pigeonhole kind
of every 10-15 minutes um let's go on to
greg do you want to do this from your
screen
sure so i'll just i'll put you to the
stream there okay nice awesome okay
okay yeah so i'm
um
let's see okay yeah so i'm gonna present
about uh
uh just a
basic overview of of what oceananigan's
is is and what's it's intended to do
um
and uh i also i should have put schmidt
futures down at the bottom but we have
klima there so maybe that covers it
um and this might be 15 minutes might be
shorter so first uh
for those of you who are julia
enthusiast but maybe not ocean
enthusiasts i just want to um oh it's
called ocenanigans so obviously it has
something to do with the ocean and
um so i think it's uh worthwhile to
spend a couple minutes explaining what
we mean by that
um so we're physicists so when we when
we talk about the ocean we're talking
about the the where
we're talking about the physics of the
ocean so oceana games is concerned with
the ocean the fluid dynamics so for us
the ocean
is um
a fluid it's a salty
variable temperature fluid which means
that gravitational forces
um
density differences in density are
important for the um
the fluid dynamics and it's in a complex
domain so
you know
we have continents we have
c mounts we have rough bathymetry
so those are the kinds of things that
are important to us
and i guess it's also worth mentioning
that
the obviously the earth is a sphere so
the ocean is um in a thin spherical
shell
on the surface of the earth
um but we also that's an important use
case for oceanians um but we're also
interested in idealized problems that
um
uh
where processes occur might occur in
things like rectangles for example
um the scales of interest in physical
oceanography just you know writ broadly
uh range from
uh they actually they you could you
could say they are actually smaller than
hundreds of meters but i'll just say
that ocean's it's
it's a sort of designed to
treat problems that the smallest scales
are around meters to hundreds of meters
and the largest problems span the whole
earth so thousands of kilometers
um
and
what oceanians is
um
you know getting
more into the details it's uh
it's the code that solves partial
differential equations that model
the fluid dynamics of the ocean so it's
a physical model for the earth's ocean
um
and we also so it's not we don't
specialize in
other aspects of oceanography like
chemistry
or biology but we do support
um coupling
uh
the core models for the physics of the
ocean with models for chemistry and
biology
um okay so
that's my introduction to the what the
ocean is
now ocenanigans is a julia library that
as i said
we use to model the ocean
and i'm calling it a library
deliberately
for people who are
you know for julia enthusiasts
all packages are libraries basically so
this is not a
nothing
all that interesting but i think it's
worth commenting that as a historical
note that many um ocean models in the
past were sort of
um they weren't just they weren't
written as libraries they're written
more as
um
these black boxes or boxes of varying
transparencies um
that uh
you the way that you interact with it is
you give it a text file like some kind
of input file or name list
um and it outputs data
uh but what we've tried to do with
oceaning and ocean oceananigan's like
oftentimes you use it that way but
um we've tried to design it so that um
the
the the
the steps that lead to the running of
the ocean model are more exposed so that
people can be more creative with the
experiments they're running and they
have more control
over the numerical experiments that they
build so
users of ocean indians are now julia
programmers um rather than people who
are just configuring name lists and text
files oceanics is designed for
both small and large-scale oceanography
which is another unique feature of our
somewhat unique feature there's other
models out there that do this too but
many don't
so many codes are designed either for
large scale or for small scale
what that means for us is that we have
we have models that can solve
non-hydrostatic equations
and we have models that can solve the
hydrostatic equations uh we might get
more into what that means specifically
but um we can do large eddy simulation
but we can also do global circulation
modeling
so the primary purpose of ocean antigens
um is to couple with the other
components
in an earth system model being developed
by the climate modeling alliance or
clima
and
what our our purpose there is to do
data-driven earth system modeling or a
more systematic estimate
three parameters that show up in earth
system models
um
our second vision um which we're you
know we're trying to piggyback so
we're funded to develop this earth
system model but we're developing it in
julia so we think that we can also
achieve another vision which is to
greatly accelerate and enable innovative
innovative computational oceanography um
which you know is part of what i was
saying before by building a library
where people have more control over
their numerical experiments
and it's
this is julia con so it's worth
mentioning that we um we leverage a wide
range of packages in the julia ecosystem
from kernel abstractions to support
cpu
or gpu execution
um cuda.jl
um support hopefully coming soon for amd
as well amd gpus
jld2 netcdf mpi pencil ffts
mackie for visualization
um and many more packages that i'm not
mentioning
um so ocean engines is really it's a
julia library
okay so
so just to showcase some um some
examples uh so yeah so to get more into
the details um
we use kernel abstractions as i
mentioned to do to support
multi-threaded execution on the cpu
and gpu execution using
um the same underlying code for both
cases so that's a um an important
feature of ocean engines we don't write
the model isn't written models aren't
written twice one for cpu one for gpu
we have um
prototype support for
multi-gpu execution in a single process
using some cuda features
and also prototype support for
multi-node
uh execution so that's distributed
memory
um using mpi
um but both of those are sort of works
in progress and if you want to help out
please please do
uh so the top example the first example
i'm showing i should play these again
um
is an example in a rectangular domain um
it's periodic in one direction the
direction that the flow is going in
and bounded in the other two
uh and it's it's a simulation of um
turbulence driven by the wind and
surface waves at a laboratory scale
and the bottom example is um a
a hole or a it's a it's a simulation on
the on the sphere so a global
ocean circular ocean simulation at a
quarter degree resolution which at that
resolution
um you resolve part of the what we call
the mesoscale
mesoscale eddy field which are all the
interesting
wiggles and um
and and eddies uh in visible in the uh
in that visualization
okay so i think that's
it yeah okay so that's it for the
background so um
pigeonhole probably should give people a
little bit of time to
yeah so should we go to the pigeon hole
thing and just see
there are a few questions that uh oh
yeah yeah open it up so let's go there
so
um
so our models designed to be more
deterministic since you mentioned data
driven models i think the answer is
uh
they're designed to maybe be more
authentically accurate to the real world
but you know the fluid dynamics is still
slightly chaotic and so determinism
there's certain things that are
deterministic some large-scale behaviors
we think but there's also a lot there's
a lot of interesting turbulence in these
things that means
they are also they have a stochastic
side to them as well so yes and no i
guess well right i was
no they're no more deterministic than
any other than other ocean models right
yeah i think you know the data driven
part is trying to make them
fit the real world more accurately at
some point you know we're trying to come
up with more but they're still
the level of determinism kind of is
built into the yeah the fluid dynamics
is it's a hard question because yeah
uh
there's a physical there's like a uh an
emergent stochasticity that's what chris
is talking about
um and there's also the possibility that
you would introduce explicit
stochasticity into the model but
um i would say in general though um it's
not designed to be any more or less
deterministic than existing ocean models
yeah that's
yeah
yeah so to answer the first question
we asked about the resources
um i think both of the simulations are
run on one gpu
yeah uh uh it's a v100
so we can actually fit quite complex
models on on
one gpu so the movie
where i showed which was the
i think both simulations were actually
run on titan five yeah um but we do also
run v100s yeah yeah
but the the movie the movie on the
sphere that you showed greg i think
that's on a four v100 isn't it it's kind
of about
no that's on a single titan five yeah
yeah okay i thought oh that was not the
12th we do have one that we're running
we have we have one of the simulations
that runs on four different
uh d100s which is a little bit more
resolved but up with a quarter of a
degree you can go on just 1005.
we just think almost everybody using
ocean anigen's if you're using it for um
research
um or you know practical applications
you're typically running
on a single
gpu yeah
and we're working on you know we have
this prototype support for multi-gpu
which will support even larger problems
you know some of the
really big ones yeah
okay how about this is there something
in the formulation that makes ocean
animals not suitable for atmospheric
fluid fluids maybe radiation yeah it's
radiation and we're solving for uh
incompressible flow at the moment
so if you wanna we have we had some
plans i think to put in a compressible
uh model
but it's not really
uh available yet
so let me
so uh later on in the in the
presentation we're going to get into the
internals of ocean enemies
um and uh what will what we'll describe
is that you know oceananigan's is um
it's actually this sort of sprawling
code right now
and it includes one part of it
is a
engine for finite volume calculations um
another part are utilities for running
experiments and then on top of those
um we've implemented um models for
physics
so oceans has three physics models a
shallow water model a non-hydrostatic
model and a hydrostatic model
um and so the models are responsible for
implementing um you know the specific
equations being solved so
it's just the case that right now we
haven't we don't have any equation set
that would be
i mean you can you can use like a
business non-hydrostatic approximation
as somebody was mentioning
incompressible uh approximation for some
atmospheric problems but for like a
global atmosphere um you need a slightly
different equation set and we don't have
that implemented right now but there's
nothing in if the formulation is sort of
vague but if you're talking about the
code structure there's nothing in the
code structure that prevents you from
writing a new model
um for the atmosphere yeah yeah and
radiation is not an issue
underlying engine would work also for
atmosphere
yeah yeah
so
i think we should stick with going
through a few questions before we go
back is that does that sound good to you
greg and simone yeah i think there's
most useful thing yeah
um but yeah we will get to showing some
code as well because so practical
industry uses i think oceanagans has
kind of grown up in a a research
universe first and foremost
certainly
it has a target for
climate predictability and prediction
and trying to reduce uncertainty and
climate
forecasts that people will use for you
know planning
large investments out to 30 years or
longer
it is based on a an algorithm a lot of
it's based on algorithm we call the mit
general circulation model mit gcm
that has been around longer and is
actually used kind of in
environmental studies quite often that
these days so it's used both for
research but also and and ocean elegance
could go the same way so some examples
of that are you know people use
this form of this um larger kind of
pre-existing code for looking at
environmental impacts of desalination
plants there's interesting work looking
at
sea level rise around places like
nantucket so there are some kind of
environmental
organizations that use
these algorithms
not too many using julia quite yet
those are using slightly older versions
of the same algorithm
right so basically ocean modeling
there's a lot of industrial applications
of ocean modeling in general but
nobody's using oceanic and yet for the
for those
we've only been you know ocean lining is
about two years old so it's kind of it's
a new kid on the block at the moment
the also the applications are increasing
um
you know climate change is becoming more
people are worrying about it more and
doing trying to do more about it and
that and you know the ocean is a
fundamental component of the earth
system so
those applications are increasing
okay i can try to answer this acoustic
question yeah yeah go for it
um
i think i just tried to look up what
bellop was it's like a ray tracing code
i think uh
so
i would say that something like that is
probably outside the scope of the ocean
engine's package itself but what oceans
would provide is
a temperature field
um
or a structure ocean structure
um the output of ocean endings would be
used as an input into code like bellhop
um but
we're primarily interested in following
the fluid dynamics like the like the
velocities um
and stuff like that so no plans to do
acoustic modeling but people have used
as greg says again in the mit gcm world
which is kind of the same algorithm
they've used solutions from that model
for a lot of interesting acoustic work
there's some
so the
12th of a degree simulation that um
simone
shows on a sphere i think in his in his
example which is the one i think that
does run on four gpus um
there's a similar mit gcm run we did to
that where people did some fascinating
work looking at something called the
herd island experiment and the
resolution was such that you could
actually see
so the herd arlington experiment was a
1960s acoustic
experiment where people
uh let off a loud acoustic source in the
indian ocean and then you could detect
it at bermuda and things and
explaining exactly the travel time and
where those acoustic signals were heard
has always been an interesting uh
problem that people study globally
because they turn up with a certain time
and that tells you about the state of
the ocean and things so um
that sort of global model actually is
kind of fun for doing that and there are
people who do that sort of stuff so
um
okay we'll do one more question shall we
searching for probabilistic search for
finding vessels lost at sea
anyone want to try
well not right now
um only because well mainly because
we're still like putting together like a
you know realistic
we're we're on our way towards realistic
simulations but we're not on our way
towards like a forecasting level
type of simulation
um so that's some time out
but i think people do use ocean models
for
you know yeah of course i don't know if
they
i was reading about the indian ocean
plane crash i don't think they
i think people were pretty surprised
actually where the debris ended up yeah
people tried to explain it using
circulation models and i think it wasn't
that successful sometimes they were left
with yeah but when there have been big
oil spills and things people do you know
oil is kind of a mix of
you know a kind of fluid under parcels
of blobs of
messy stuff and people
certainly use models like this for um um
looking at you know
where an oil where to go to kind of
clean up oil spills and try and um block
them and things like that yeah
so you could envision that being an
application a few years down the line
but definitely not right now
okay let's go to
let's take just a bit of code shall we
uh
yeah i think that's next on the list so
now
we have
hands
and i think
you're on again greg because you kind of
had you scheduled it really on the hook
yeah yeah
um
so do you want to share from your screen
is that
yeah that's
okay
so
the font's pretty small
oh let me get idea let's increase it
okay so the intention of this
part is so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to
um walk everyone through the process
of writing a
of well so me and simone are both going
to walk people through the process of
writing
writing a numerical experiment that
simulates something relevant to the
ocean
my example is a simple
sort of classroom level example of um
that illustrates the process of
convection
um
actually i had a slide maybe i should go
back to my i had a slide
so my my example is it illustrates the
process of convection
um and simone's
example is going to illus it's gonna so
my mine will be non-hydrostatic i'm
gonna do it on the cpu
and simone's example is gonna be
hydrostatic simulation on the sphere
on a gpu
um
and i think you've figured out all the
stuff you need to do to get that to work
um
15 minutes okay so i'm gonna go fast
um okay so my example's a simple
convection example
um and i guess if you'd like to start i
should have put the code here so let me
um
if you'd like to look at the code while
i'm talking
um
it's gonna be this is not gonna work
give me a second i'll find the link
um
so here's this here's our repo so the
code i'm going to present is in this
ocean convection dot jl um
script okay so if you'd like to this is
what i'm gonna i'm gonna code up the
script like line by line um but if you'd
like to see what we're aiming towards at
the end you can look at this
okay so um
just for those of you who don't know
convection what so
people define convection different ways
uh when when we say convection we're
talking about gravity-driven flow
um due to density gradients um and a
typical example is density gradients
associated with temperature
so for example if you heat a pan on the
stove you're heating it from below
and hot fluid is light so the hot fluid
wants to rise and that process
produces
turbulence turbulent convection
it's a fundamental process in the ocean
and the atmosphere
and in this example i'm going to write a
script that models convection in just
two dimensions that's going to make the
problem um a little cheaper
computationally
and because
vertical accelerations are important
in convection i'm going to use
oceanagen's non-hydrostatic model um to
to for this problem
okay so
let's
see where okay so i just here's the repo
again um
and the so the script is here ocean
convection
um i'm going to start a new
file
um an attempt to reproduce this
so we'll see yeah let me get this
as a reference
okay so ocean convection
demo
so i don't know this is julia khan
um so many people may be familiar with
julius package manager but um
in case you're not
uh
you install the way to install
oceananigans is to
open up julia so i've already done that
i ran the script to pre-compile
everything so this goes a little faster
um and you type add oceananigans
julia i mean oak standings is a
registered package in the julia general
registry so that should find it and
install it
um sometimes there's issues with
versioning if you have other packages in
your environment
but that's the basic process and i've
already done that here so i'm not going
to press enter there
um
okay now when we're writing a script
first thing we have to do is we have to
um say using the shannon again so i'm
gonna write that
um
and then the next
well
uh let me just a second
okay and then the next step is to
is to uh so the okay so we're trying to
model convection in a two-dimensional
domain so we have to the first thing to
do is we have to build a grid that um
divides the domain of interest into
small boxes
that's in oceanic is using a finite
volume method so building the grid is
the first fundamental step in
building a numerical experiment
so in this case i'm going to use the
rectilinear grid
which is for problems in rectangles um
so this is this this can represent
domains that are one two or three
dimensional um which each dimension
orthogonal to the other um
and i'm going to use a modest
so i'm going to do a two-dimensional
grid and i'm going to use a modest size
64 squared this will run hopefully
pretty quickly on
my mac
um
we call the three dimensions are called
xyz so i'm gonna i'm gonna design this
experiment to be an x and z
and i'm gonna make x go from 0 to 128
the units are not specified but let's
say we're using meters here
um
and so this is you know this will be two
meter grid spacing in the horizontal and
as is customary in the ocean we put zero
at the surface so
the z direction direction is going to go
from minus 64 to zero
um and finally i'm going to specify a
what we call a topology
so this
um the topology defines um the nature of
the of the directions so
um in this case my x direction is going
to be periodic
my y direction i don't have y direction
so i'm going to i'm going to label that
flat which means i'm not that that means
that it's
it's dropping out of the problem and i
the problem is only two-dimensional
um and i'm going to say the z-direction
is bounded which means that i have solid
walls at the top and the bottom
okay so let's run this
okay so it ran quickly
and produced a grid
um and
chris has asked me to chris you can jump
in if you
you asked me to illustrate the help
functionalities
can you somebody's asking on pigeon
health you can increase the font a bit
as well i don't know i think
um
okay
i was answering some other questions but
i just noticed that
but yeah well greg does that but there
are for all of the functions there's
some nice help so yeah if you show that
that'd be kind of fun to see as well you
can just right
so okay so here you can see i call the
object grid and you can see it's created
here 64 by one which is the y direction
by by 64.
periodic next bounded in z
if we want to know if we want to know
any of anything else that we might pass
directly in your grid we can use the
help
so if we
type question mark and then rectilinear
grid we get this very long help string
that gives you all sorts of other
information maybe one key thing to note
is that
implicitly i didn't specify the
architecture
so it's it's the default is cpu
but if you want to run the gpu then you
change the first argument here
gpu like that
um my mac doesn't have a gpu so i'm not
going to do that
okay okay so we've got a grid um and now
the next thing to build is a model so
we're gonna build a non-hydrostatic
model
um on the grid that we've um
we've built let's run this again
it takes a little bit of time because
it's
allocating memory for all the fields in
the model um okay so we've got now you
built a model you got a non-hydrostatic
model on a rectilinear grid
it's using this particular time stepping
method
um atom bash second order quasi second
order adam's bashfort bashforth method
it has no tracers
which are the you know the um
fields that are affected by the velocity
field
no turbulence closure no buoyancy and no
coriolis so um
the fact that we don't have any tracers
or buoyancy means that we're not gonna
be able to model convection with this
model
so um
or i should use another word besides
model we're not going to be able to
uh
simulate convection with this model
so the next thing to do is to add
tracers to the model and what i'm going
to do here is i'm going to use a tracer
that represents um the value
of the tracer it's it's analogous to
temperature um but it's called buoyancy
um so i'm going to call it
and i'm going to use a
buoyancy model that the buoyant
acceleration incurred in the fluid is
proportional to
the value of buoyancy so to do that i
write this
tracer
run this again
readable
okay
okay so now we're gonna rebuild the
model
um
and you can see now we have a tracer
called b
and the buoyancy um the buoyancy models
the buoyancy tracer and gravity is
pointing in the minus z direction okay
so that's our the typical experience on
earth where gravity points down
um okay so what does it mean to have a
field so i
so now this model has tracers a tracer
called b and what that means is that
it's allocated memory um
for a field that's going to represent
buoyancy
and that so that memory so okay let's
see so
that memory is wrapped in an object that
we call field with capital f
um
and you can see that uh we have a little
summary of the values of the field down
here
and it's zero everywhere so the first
thing to do is to change so what i want
to model an initial value problem in
which
um the buoyancy is unstable initially
and then and then which causes
convection so to do that i'm going to
have to change the values of buoyancy so
um for that i write um okay so let's see
i'm going to first the first thing i'm
going to try is i'm going to make
buoyancy
um
i'm going to make this variable called
epsilon
function epsilon um which is
uh
randomly normally distributed random
variable
uh and i'm just going to set buoyancy
equal to epsilon
so if you rerun this
and look again
okay so now we see that writing set
um
so this what set does is that it changes
the values of a field um and then this
is a convenience function that changes
all the values of any field in the model
all at the same time so here i wrote set
model with point c
um equal to this function and so it
evaluated that function on every every
grid point
and as a result
we have a buoyancy field has a small i
mean the mean should if we had enough
resolution it would be closer to zero i
guess but um you can see it has some
maximum minimum values here so it's
randomly distributed and then
just to okay let's see so i haven't done
any visualization yet so it's useful to
look at the points field to see what it
looks like so let's create a
visualization
i'm just going to use mackie for that
heat map
so let's see if we can
see what that does
okay
okay so cool so okay
so so far we've created a model
it has
a buoyancy tracer
um which represents point acceleration
applied to the fluid
and we were able to change the
distribution of buoyancy to be uh
randomly random
um and so this is what the buoyancy
looks like in our 64 by 64 domain
um
okay so now i'm going to do something
slightly less trivial i'm going to give
make it an unstable distribution so give
me just give me a moment i have less
uh i have less time to explain exactly
what i'm doing here but i'll try that so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
make it
i'm going to make a buoyancy um
distribution that's hot on the bottom
and cold on the top kind of similar to
the situation that would occur at least
transiently in the pan that you heated
up on the stove
and i'm just going to make it a tange
function so that has a smooth
distribution for that
um so let's
see i'm gonna
i'm gonna put it so i wanna make it
so that it transitions from hot to cold
in the middle of the domain and has a
width of four meters so that's what that
means
and then i'm going to
reduce the amplitude of the noise
compared to this buoyancy perturbation
okay
so let's see so that's my so that's the
initial buoyancy distribution i like to
use so let's see if we can
it works
nice okay well yeah
okay so
oh there's no filler bar but anyways
yellow is warm and
blue is called luckily
um
and uh yeah so it's tang it usually
doesn't depend on x except for the
randomness the ram the small you can
kind of see the random noise a little
bit you might think it's dirt on your
screen but
there's a little bit of randomness that
helps the kick the instability off we
need a little bit of randomness for that
um
yeah it looks good actually i think
we're ready to we're ready to try to run
this i think at least um
preliminarily
preliminary simulation of this scenario
so let's do that uh okay so
so that so in order to so i have a model
that represents the physical problem i'd
like to solve but the next thing i have
to do is i i'm going to build a
simulation which will time step this
model forward in time and potentially do
some other things that might um
be important uh for my scientific
problem like
saving output to disk or maybe logging
something to the screen so i know what's
going on in the simulation
um and so for that i'm going to use
oceanagen's simulation
object with the capital s
which requires me to give it a time step
um so i'm just going to guess what the
time step might need to be
and um i'll run it for i'll turn afraid
of balance and iterations
okay
let's see what happens okay so now so
the way the script is structured now
i set the buoyancy field to this tange
to build a simulation and then i plot
what the buoyancy is after i run it
so let's
do that might take some take a little
bit more time to run
let's say not too much time
okay now it's running i think it's
running but i'm not
it's kind of just sitting there so
one thing that's pretty useful okay so
it was doing the initial time step yeah
one thing that's useful actually is to
print let's let's look at the cells for
you oh it's doing something
nice it's starting to convect i think
um
so one thing that's useful um
you know is one thing while simulation
is running especially if it's a
long-running simulation we typically
want to print something to the screen
that tells us what the progress of the
simulation is
um and so we can do that using this
feature called a callback
um so that's the first thing i'll just
illustrate how we would do that with um
with oceanic and simulation so going to
a callback is basically a function
that runs at a specified schedule so
here the function is just going to print
something to the screen and say it's
going to print the
model iteration
and
the time
and i'm sort of pretending to use
physical units so i'll use this function
pretty time which will tell me that it's
seconds or minutes or whatever
okay so and then i want to add
this is a callback
i'll print it every ten iterations
let's run it
for a few thousand maybe something large
is gonna happen if we can run it a
little longer
okay let's see how that works oops i
have an error
similar oh
call backs yeah so this
this callbacks property is a ordered
dictionary um to which we add all the
callbacks
um okay nice okay so now it's running
it's executing that callback every ten
iterations and
we have some more faith that the
simulation is actually running and it's
not
paused okay
okay it ran longer but
um
[Music]
if you look closely
you'll notice that uh there's
a lot of variation grid point to grid
point in this output
now if you're um if you're a
computational scientist you might
understand immediately what's going on
um but for those of you who don't
i'll just explain that um we set up this
model
and
maybe it's worth showing that the model
is associated with an advection scheme
here but it's a centered second order
advection scheme which is a
low order
um
non-dissipative infection scheme so we
have
um little or known numerical dissipation
in the problem and no um explicit
dissipation or no diffusivity or
viscosity and so as a result
um
as a result the simulation is pretty
noisy um non-physical real fluids have
dissipation
so
to model this to better model this
problem i'm going to have to add some
dissipation
um and i think i'd also like to use a
higher order advection scheme which will
produce higher quality results as well
so i'm going to
add a new advection scheme
arduino
that's the best infection scheme we have
right now
and uh let's also add i'm also going to
add a turbulence closure so i'm going to
add a
isotropic
constant
viscosity and diffusivity
using the turbulence closure scalar
diffusivity
and since i since i cheated and ran this
problem a lot in advance i know that 0.1
is a good value to choose
for this domain in this case
so
my my domain is 128 meters by 64 meters
so
this diffusivity is actually a
turbulence closure it's a model for
turbulence that's occurring below the
scale of the grid this is not the
molecular diffusivity but if you did if
you wanted to
you could attempt to model you could
attempt to use a diffusivity that
corresponds to the molecular diffusivity
of the fluid in which case you would be
doing what's called direct numerical
simulation but here we're we're not
doing that we're doing some we're doing
an idealized model of the problem
um okay so
let's run it again
okay so we're using we know
it's gonna take
might take some time to
oh
not too much time okay
it's
running it takes a little bit longer
um as models get more complicated they
get more and more expensive especially
with the higher order infection scheme
but not too much time
okay
well it doesn't look so bad though
um
cool
all right
yeah so
someone clapped was that excuse yeah
good cursed clapping yeah chris is
excited
all right so
let's see i'm probably over my 15
minutes so
i think that as a to to wrap this up and
you can if you look at the script on the
repo you'll see a bunch of other things
i
included in this like
oh let's do two more things okay two
more things i'd like i'm gonna i'm gonna
save some output to disk and then i'm
gonna make an animation those are the
two things i think that are important
okay
so
so so far all i did was i ran a
simulation and i plotted the field at
the end but typically we're interested
in more
um
more than just what the distribution is
at the end of the simulation we want to
know its time history
um so to inspect that we save output to
disk and for to save output to disk we
use ocean engines output writers so
i'll show you what that looks like
briefly
um okay so
if i want to so let's see
i just want to have my cheat sheet here
ready
okay
so
we're going to add an output writer to
this
call it jld2 because we're going to use
the jld2 output writer
and the first argument to the output
writer is a model the second argument is
a named tuple
of fields
that represent the output so in this
i'll i'm gonna do two outputs the first
output i'm gonna do is just the buoyancy
field itself so
um i'll show you so that's if i if i
wanted to output the buoyancy field i
just created a named couple and i'm
gonna call it b that's what's called
inside the model
um and then the next thing i give to it
is a schedule
so this is
this is going to tell me
this is saying when
i'd like to output and
let's run it let's run it like let's run
for 4000 and i'll output what should i
do
every
every i'll do every if i do every 400
it'll be 10 i'll do i'll do every 200
iterations so
iteration 200
um
i also need to give it a file name so
i'm going to call it um
convection
and
i often we often include this
flag override existing which means if
there's an existing file just overwrite
it that doesn't matter the first time i
run it but subsequent times there's
going to be existing data and i want to
delete it every time i go
okay so this so i added an output writer
and okay so everything's okay so let's
just run it again and see actually just
for this first thing when i make the
movie i'll run it for
let's just make it a little bit cheaper
so this goes faster so
i just want to show that this
if we build this um
oh
did i
okay i said overwriting this thing
equals false
true because we want true okay let's run
it again
okay so yeah we have a we have a jld2
file in here but it actually may have
been created by a different simulation
so i'm going to remove that
um
and okay
i knew that was happening because that
warning that was flashing on the screen
okay so now okay so i ran it again and
it created this jle2 file
here and we could look into it but um
let's let's not just for the sake of
time um suffice to say that it has data
and if we trust that everything worked
correctly
the data is
um has it has a buoyancy field in it
time series of the buoyancy field saved
every 200 iterations
so that's how you um build output with
oceanic is now one of ocean engine's
most interesting features is its ability
to
um save output that um
consists of
neat not arbitrary but but complicated
calculus and arithmetic operations apply
to the model fields
so
and why is that so for example one
interesting thing that we might want to
compute is the vorticity of the fluid
which quantifies the rate at which each
fluid parcel is rotating
so the vorticity requires taking
derivatives of the velocity field so
um
in the oceans we can i'm going to call
it z
and to so
let's actually let me show you this in
the we'll have a little thing on the um
on on on this feature uh
later on in the thing but i'll just give
a little introduction to it so if i
wanted to vine and define an object that
reference for represents vorticity
i just i write it um
and i always get the sign wrong so
the actual vorticity might be minus this
thing but in any case so i i have three
fields that represent the velocity
components
and um
to create an object that represents
vorticity i write this expression that
looks
very similar to the mathematical the way
you would write it with pencil
the d by dx of u minus d by dz of w and
that creates this object called an
operation which is a lazy representation
of the computation of vorticity
okay so
okay so i
showed you how to create an operation so
what we're going to do is we're going to
put xz here and we're going to say that
we want to save not just b but also xz
um
okay so that's how you so so so this
illustrates
how you can you can schedule output
that it not just consists of fields but
also computations performed on fields
and you can also
um you can slice them so you know if you
have a 3d simulation you typically don't
want to output 3d data every time step
and you can also average them in time
before outputting them
um okay so i'm not gonna before i run
this again let's create a visualization
so
i'll expand this
simple
um this simple thing into so okay so
to create a visualization
i'm going to what i have to do is i have
to load the data
um you can load
you can load the data several ways some
people prefer to visualize in python
um
some people save with net cdf for that
purpose i think you can also look at
jld2 data in python
but what i like to do i like to use
julia
um and oceanic is includes this nice
feature um useful for analysis called
field time series
so i'm going to construct a field time
series that rep that's a time series of
the data that was saved in my file so um
the first argument is
pushing convection.jld2
and then the second argument is the name
of the field that the time series
consists of
and now i'm going to do some macky stuff
that i don't know
um
i don't know how many people are mackie
aficionados but
um
what i'm going to do is let's see
let me create two
candles in my figure
um
and then
i'm gonna use this
let's see two panels
i'm gonna do a slider
i'm going to create a slider so we can
um
we can explore the data after we create
it and use this function called lift
that's very magical
it allows me to
visualize the evolving data
so i don't need that should be enough
okay
okay so let's run it again
for
four thousand that we wanted to do
stay if i made a table or not somewhere
i'll find out
hmm four thousand
yeah it takes a lot oh we don't have to
run it again after this so
okay there's a problem
happened
um
that's kind of unexpected
so that there's 21 values
oh greg what's going on
well now i'm not sure
[Music]
uh
things look pretty good
don't you know observable for that
let's have a look
oh
that's what happened thanks money
that's what i meant to write okay yeah
and here i'll just um i won't run the
simulation again
yeah
sharp eyes
yeah so i had this n variable but it was
being taken from something else
not the right thing
okay so here
okay great
great
okay so
yeah so it did
yep and you can see there's some
convection let's see uh
pretty coarse but you know that's life
that's life on stream yard um there you
go
yeah so right so here we go so we're
visualizing so you know beautiful very
very our initial condition
the pop panels buoyancy the bottom panel
vorticity
as we step it forward
um we start off everything starts off as
random noise
um but then we see this instability
develop um
this is called rayleigh taylor
instability is that right yeah um
uh so the hot fluid is rising into the
cold fluid um
associated with a vorticity signal
um
and then we get some eddies and things
swirl around and start mixing
so yeah next time
time you put a saucepan on your stove
this is what's going on yeah
more or less same physics anyways
if you really wanted to model this the
pan you have to use a boundary condition
with a heat flux which you could also do
in ocean against but i didn't illustrate
that
but yeah so
you know the github script has it shows
you how to make an animation with color
bars and save it as a movie
etc um but this is the basic part
okay there were a couple of youtube
questions as well because people can ask
questions i think or they can ask
questions on the stream
so one was just what what's a tracer do
you want to try and explain what you
meant by tracer just said that
yeah so so the there's two types of
fields i mean in the non-hydrostatic
model there's two types of fields one is
the velocity field which we represent
through three velocity components um and
that you know that's like
quantifying the motion of the fluid
a tracer
is a quantity that's carried by the
fluid so um a temperature heat is a
tracer so you know if if you have a
current moving then it carries uh it
carries its temperature with it um
salinity is a tracer and you know other
chemical species are tracers
um
so hopefully that explains it
yep uh
and then
okay should we go and uh
look at pigeonhole briefly i think
someone said can we stick a rigid
structure in would that be a boundary is
that on this is that i don't know if
that's the ocean or
all the sessions are concatenated into
one stream yard comment thing so
i think that's about uh immersed
boundaries so i'm gonna yeah so simone
is gonna show how to put continents in
here so that's kind of like a rigid
structure so we'll see that it's very
complex let's see if we can
do that put us into yeah so the stream
yard ones
um
i think people have been answering them
behind the scenes but maybe i know if
you set topology
periodic flat periodic on a rectangular
rectilinear grid would that be like an
ocean
on a taurus
kind of yeah i think um
typically you do periodic periodic flat
more than periodic flap periodic that's
kind of the the the last dimension which
is
called z is usually our vertical
dimension which we kind of
don't think about
topologically it is a taurus yeah yeah
but
but on an actual taurus it surfaces
curves that changes things a little bit
so here it's like you know that's but
that's what it means to be periodic yeah
that's one way to think about it um
and then
there's a what kind of
so i think our girl was you were asking
i think this question in particular was
asking about we know i'll just go and
look inside i think because i answered a
bit but
um
simone do you want to say tiny bit about
we know and diffusion because greg was
looking at centered second order so um
with our wiener scheme we actually have
uh inbuilt
uh diffusion
so we don't
uh we don't need to add some explicit
diffusivity because we know should
actually take care it's it calculates
the reconstruction dynamically based on
the field
so um it allows you to to run without uh
a diffusivity that you would put in
uh for stability so our code is stable
without uh an explicit diffusivity in
the shallow water model
specifically so we don't need to have uh
uh an additional diffusivity
but we have some models for
uh we need some closures to represent
what happens at smaller scales
so we have closures for viscosity
uh not for diffusivity at the moment
so we have some closures to express how
velocity
uh how turbulence mixes velocity or
momentum in at uh scales that are
smaller than the grid
okay there's one let's do one more which
was what does hydrostatic mean maybe
just you either greg or simone you could
say a little bit about the difference
between kind of large scale and small
scale models so greg was looking at a
non-hydrostatic thing and simone's going
to look at hydrostatic
yeah so the hydrostatic approximation
that um
what we mean by that it's when um it's
referring to pressure so when pressure
is hydrostatic
um it means that it's uh determined by a
static or quasi-static balance between
uh in the ocean and against cases
between the vertical pressure gradient z
pressure gradient
um and the buoyancy field
so
in a in a hydrostatic model
that
the about that balance dominates the
vertical momentum equation and there's
no vertical acceler acceleration whereas
in a non-hydrostatic model we explicitly
model um vertical acceleration so
hydro the hydrostatic model is
appropriate for fluids that have very
small aspect ratios like the ocean um so
the horizontal scale is much larger than
the vertical scale
um so that's
that that's like basically the
yeah
nice yeah and then yeah there's one last
question i guess so we just touch on all
of them what's special about the first
time step why does it take very long
compared with the other time steps and
that's kind of answered in line here but
yeah usually yeah it's about compilation
so
julia has to go through all the
functions that we use on pre-compiling
the first time so that takes a
a lot of extra time
but then after that you know we do
thousands of time steps normally in a
real simulation so you amortize that
cost over yeah a large number of time
steps
okay you're filling up to
okay knowing a global thing simone try
to show an ocean now yeah let's see
that's what everybody's been waiting for
i know should i share it wait a second i
mean
yeah we can uh
yeah i think
are you sharing
should i share it maybe
i can do it for you i just did it i
think i think there you go is there the
size larger pretty small to me but let
me
if you need a bigger font
but so i'm gonna try to do like greg
here and
uh now give you all the steps to
actually build uh an ocean model with uh
with the shenanigans so give all the
ingredients that we need and see if in
the end we actually have
something that resembles a real ocean uh
it's not going to be the most
fantastical resolved ocean because
yeah this is the resource we have here
but let's see what uh where we can get
so i have i have the code here on github
it's uh gpuo and cmotion.gl if you want
to go it's going to follow it
um but i'm going to try to code live and
for who doesn't have a gpu
uh i have this instruction at the
beginning that tells you to run on the
gpu
and if you don't have it and you want to
code along you just have to change this
this line to uh
cpu and everything will work properly on
your cpu
so if you want to try it you can do that
okay so let's see where we can get
um let's do ocean demo.html
let's go like this
so first of all uh we need a grid to
simulate the ocean but this time
rectilinear grid is not enough
it's not because we need to
um we need to discretize the sphere
so shenanigans for this has a
lot to do launches grid
and this grid will have instead of
having the cartesian x and y direction
we'll have uh the la the longitude
direction on the on the x and the
last direction on the y
so uh let's start giving it a size
the modest size here
not huge
um
[Music]
we have to specify a longitude
and in this case we want to give it the
degrees
of the uh of the grid are launched
increase and we go from
minus hundred and 180 degrees so this
will the script will wrap around
the whole earth
and we have to give it a a latitude
uh span
and this this grid is um it's it
describes a lot to a longitude so when
you go to uh to the poles the the
longitude circles actually collapse into
uh into a singularity so we cannot give
it from minus 90 to 90 but we have to
stay away from the poles
and we do this by specifying
by just pulling up a little bit short
from the poles in this case i give like
minus 84 to 84
degrees and the specific numbers are
because i run this problem and have
boundary conditions that are set on this
inside plate
and then we need a z direction
let's give it an ocean depth
in this case we start with a depth of
3.6 kilometers which is
kind of realistic
um
okay so i hope okay i have a
pre-compiled everything so now we have
uh lots of longitude grids that will run
on a cpu
um
and it spans from -100 to 180 degrees
with um
a grid spacing of 2.8 degrees in the
launches in the last direction and we're
300 meters in the vertical direction
so the first thing that we can do to
improve this grid is um we don't have so
many so many grid points we actually
have only 12 uh point in the vertical
direction
so what we can do is uh since in the
ocean everything really happens at the
surface and not much happens at the
bottom we can actually stretch the grid
the grid towards the surface so we can
make better use of our vertical level so
let's start actually
giving some parameters here to make it a
little bit easier
so to um to
to make the uh green ocean elegance uh
stretched in in one direction you can
pass it either
an array or a function of the index
in this case i've
already already defined a function
it works but you can define whatever
kind of function it just has to be
monochronic with the index so you can so
you can have a stretch grid
um
let's see
sigma
and this
[Music]
how did i define it
i'll find
that
[Music]
one
[Music]
um
so sorry this should be okay
so in this case this grid will this this
uh grid spacing will have a spacing
which will depend on on the
on the index
and should uh should decrease as as you
increase the the decay
[Music]
wait a
second a little bit
how's it going let's have a look um
here
this should be correct
and then we have to define
you could always run it and see what it
looks like
yes
oh you have to
i see you have to get the um
the z coordinate from the delta z right
but that's in the grid yeah you can get
out of the grid
nice
this
and then we can define
creases
which will be um
which will be so if if um
if k is our first point
then
that's the bottom
that will be the bottom of it
otherwise
we'll have
uh m minus z plus the sum of the
previous delta z
uh typo
minus lz not underscore
right there
nice
okay so this should give us a function
that
has faces that go from mine to z to zero
in uh in increasing order
let's see how it looks like
oh i am forget to save it yes
okay
and then i have to pass the grid of
course
okay now so if you compare this grid
with this one you'll see that here we
have a z which goes from minus 300 minus
3.6 kilometers to zero again well it's
variable space in space so it has a
delta z that goes
from 124 near the top
to 577 meters near the bottom
now as was mentioned before
uh for an ocean we also need a
bathymetry so we need to uh
we need to give it uh the continents and
on the bottom of the ocean and for this
one i have i actually have given a file
that you can you can
load in
uh i think it's called
the symmetry underscore juliacon
okay
if i'm not mistaken that
the uh of this
okay
well this is what our bottom issue looks
like um
it's just is just an array of uh an x
and y size which will tell us tell to
our grid let me make it a little bit
smaller
that will tell
our grid what is the actual bottom of uh
of our ocean
so
uh if we overlay this one to our this
this uh this array to our grid so when i
make that bigger yeah there you go okay
if we overlay this uh this array to our
grid
um
the grid will know that whatever it's
above it will be part of the fluid
domain and whatever is below it uh will
actually be part of a continent or will
be covered by terrain so everything will
be masked to zero and not be calculated
as you can see
this bactimetry is kind of coarse but it
has everything that we need it has
africa
here
in america some some bottom gear some
ridges
so to overlay this to uh to our grid we
have the
we have the
uh immersed grid type so let's call this
the line grid maybe
by
grid
we can immerse this with our merge
boundary grid
so this type
yeah
in this way we'll know that
we'll take this grid
and this grid will know that uh whatever
is below the the the timing array will
be covered from the computation
save it
okay
so this grid is actually an inverse
boundary grid which has a bottom
that goes from minus six kilometers to
zero
so zero is going to be where our
continents are
and this is going to be the most deep
uh part of the ocean which we actually
don't
touch because our grade only goes to
-3.6 kilometers
um
so now we define the grid
and the next part
is to define our physics the physical
problem
so to define our physics we first need
to uh we have several uh parts that we
have to define
uh one of the first one is the the
coriolis force so um
the the earth is actually rotating
this
the earth is rotating
so we have to uh express this in in our
model
um we have several ways to express the
coriolis force so you can be on a plane
or you can be on a small patch of the
earth but in this case we want to have
the
we want to have a way to represent the
whole sphere so we have a type which is
called hydrostatic
spherical coriolis
which we can give a rotation rate
uh in this case let's put rotation rate
of one
and then we'll have
our model will know
that um our our sphere is spinning with
a one degree
uh radian per second of course this is a
little bit too high for earth so uh we
can take this away and we'll get
automatically by default the
by default location rate of the earth
which in this case is
um in the order of 1 to the minus e at
the minus five
and ten to the minus five
uh the second
um part of the physics that we have to
specify is our buoyancy
and uh greg used
a buoyancy tracer but here we have a
method to specify
uh that we actually have
the voice depends
on uh temperature and salinity
in this case we have
uh we can specify seawater buoyancy
and
this means that our buoyancy will depend
on uh on a temperature through uh to a
terminal expansion coefficient
and uh to a salinity through a highline
contraction coefficient so we have to
remember when we specify the model that
we have to pass in uh temperature
transcendence tracers because there will
be need for buoyancy calculation
again we can uh now we as as greg said
before we have to specify the facility
because we have to we need a way to um
to model everything that happens
um
under the
the in subreddit scales so uh we need we
need to we the way to represent what
what the mixing that happens uh within
one grid cell
and we do this throughout through a
diffusivity
uh an artificial diffusivity artificial
viscosity
um
we need to do this in a vertical
direction and the horizontal direction
but
our grid is very anisotropic because uh
the vertical direction if you see the
the the grid our vertical direction has
a spacing of about 100 meters
while our
horizontal direction
has a spacing of about three
three degrees of a circle of the whole
earth and that results in in roughly
in roughly
300 kilometers so a grid cell is 300
kilometers wide and about 100 meters uh
tall so um our diffusivity a lot much
more can happen in the horizontal
direction and then in the vertical
direction so for this reason we need a
much higher uh diffusivity in the
horizontal than the vertical direction
so for horizontal
diffusivity
we can specify
of
horizontal scalar diffusivity
uh with this quality uh we have to keep
it quite large here because as i said
there is there are uh 300 kilometers
that we have to cover
so one to the power of five it's a good
value and the fusibility of
one of the power two
is also a good value here in the
vertical direction on the other hand
um since our vertical scales are much
smaller
we need a much smaller
diffusivity
and that is about
we can use one
and
20 of the minus three and i already know
this week's around this already um but
they scale roughly with the with the
with the grid size
and another another thing that we can
specify for the vertical
uh diffusivity
is that since our our
heights are very small we will probably
be limited in in time stepping if we if
we just run it like this because the
diffusion will happen very fast so we
need we need to have a time step that
represent that diffusion
so in this case we can actually specify
give it a give it as an argument
uh
vertically implicit time discretization
so this will tell our model that
specifically this closure over here
will not be stepped in time explicitly
but will be stepped in time implicitly
and to do that uh chris is going to say
later how solvers work
but we have to solve a tree diagram
system and in this way we're not limited
in the in the time step
um
again we're going to use a hydrostatic
model so that's going to be different
from what greg showed
and we have no way to uh to represent
convection because combustion can can
happen only in a non-hydrostatic model
so exactly what greg was showing of
having a a hot fluid
um
below a cold fluid could not happen in
in our simulation so we need a way to
express the mixing without having a
vertical velocity
and we do that with uh with a model
which which targets the mixing when this
situation happens so exactly when you
have something light
that is that is below something
heavy
and in oceanography we call this
convective adjustment
because it's just a way to represent
convection
where we cannot
represent convection
and we have several models for this but
the more simple it's um
it's just a vertical diffusivity
it's just a vertical diffusivity
that um
that happens when you have when you have
an unstable
fluid situation
just
and we have to specify convective
diffusivity
we keep a little bit higher than what we
have
in our background diffusivity
uh so these are all the closures that
we'll need for our model we don't need
anything else
um
let's hook the front
now come back to adjustment if you come
back from adjustment vertical
uh how would they specified
the typing error
convective case that yeah so
this is a virtual diffusivity so we have
to specify convective cases
okay
so we have our closures which are
um horizontal vertical diffusivity and
uh
convective adjustment
we have our coriolis
force which is
values and latitudes and we have our
buoyancy model
now uh
another thing that we specify
are boundary conditions
because uh at the moment our uh our
ocean is still nothing is happening so
we need to add some forcing somewhere
and um
our ocean will have will have a u
velocity so there's a velocity along the
longitude a v velocity along the along
the latitude a temperature and a
salinity
so we need to specify boundary
conditions for these quantities
now
i already have prepared some boundary
conditions for the
for this problem
and you can you can look at them in the
file
boundary condition juliacon so i can
include them
under conditions
okay so these boundary conditions are
actually uh 2d arrays
are two of the arrays of the of size
and x and y
because they represent what happens at
the surface of the ocean so at the
surface of the ocean you have uh you
have winds and winds push
your your velocity field
and are represented by these uh tau x
and tawaii turns which are stress
um are the stress that the the wind
imposes on the surface of the ocean
and then we have also a
temp a surface temperature that we will
use to uh as a boundary condition for
the temperature field and there's the
effect of um of the the sun heating the
earth at the equator and they're losing
um
heat through through through radiation
or convection
i can show you a little bit how these
um
arrays look like
so first of all let's import let's
import them here let's call them
wax is our wind
in
in the launch directions
x
and we have our y
y is gonna be r
and in the y
direction and let's call it ts
our surface temperature
okay
so these are how these
[Music]
these
um arrays look like so just put it a
little bit higher the way i don't really
see here
okay
um
this is the wind
is the wind
uh stress in the longitudinal direction
so we have strong winds
in the southern ocean pushing
the flow eastward
and uh strong winds also in the north
atlantic while in the equator we have
winds pushing the other direction
uh you can see that once you are a
little bit coarse but this is the
resolution that we have and you see that
where the continents are we don't really
have any wind because we don't need it
um
this is the
a wind stretch in the light of cooling
direction
that's a little bit less
extendable structure
and it pretty sure has some values
and then we have the surface temperature
which of course it's
the ocean is hot near the equator where
the the the sun rays are perpendicular
and colder near the arctic and in
antarctic
um so how do we pass this this boundary
conditions to the model first of all
um
we have
we have three different
uh boundary condition types
so we have value boundary conditions
this is your your typical
political dirichlet boundary conditions
um we have gradient boundary conditions
and this is
your just this imposes a gradient so is
your normal under condition
um
and we can impose a flux so this is
actually the boundary function that
we're interested in
because uh the stress the the stress
imposed by the wind is actually a flux
momentum in the ocean
so uh we can specify the boundary
condition
for ump
as simply as doing this flux boundary
condition
and
x
something that i forgot to mention
is that if we run this on a gpu
which we didn't specify yet because we
have to specify here arcgpu which i
forgot to do and pass it as
greg said as an argument to the grid
um if we run on the gpu
these arrays have to be defined on a gpu
so we have a utility for that
um you know shenanigans which is just
art array
of the architecture
and the
array in question
[Music]
in this case um our tau x
is nothing but a q array so arc array
just
just moves your copies your your your
array from from the cpu to the gpu and
the other way around if you specify here
cpu so it's just utility but we need
this array on the gpu if we're going to
run our model on the gpu
so now we have our u boundary condition
utah boundary condition which is a flux
boundary condition and has this array
as the the actual boundary
so whenever we're going to go in in the
model it's going to pick up the ij
location of this this array and impose
it as a flux to the to the surface
do the same thing for the b velocity
and for the temperature
we could
uh define
the final value boundary condition
because we could prescribe the value of
the temperature to be equal to the
surface temperature and that would be
will look something like this
so if we do this um
we
force the temperature at the surface to
be to be equal to the to the prescribed
temperature but we don't really want to
do this now because uh then all the
dynamics of the surface will not be uh
represented because we'll fix the
temperature of the surface what we want
to do is to give a relaxation to the
temperature so we want the temperature
to relax to to the surface temperature
that we prescribe so that we can allow
it to to be modified at the surface
and to do this
uh we can prescribe a flux boundary
condition
uh so we're actually forcing the
temperature to to a prescribed value
and we can pass a function to the to the
boundary condition so if we if we pass a
function to the boundary condition the
function will be evaluated
at the boundary and used as a flux force
so let's call it restoring temperature
and we can define here this function
and this function will will give us
a function
and this function will give us
as the return value the flux evaluated
at the ij location that we require
so the
the signature of this function is the ij
location at which you have to evaluate
the flux
bit as basically all of our functions
our clock this clock is holds the time
of the simulation on the iteration so in
case you want to have a boundary
condition that changes with time you
have this information passing through
through this clock
and then we pass the fields these fields
are all the fields that are that the
model holds so in this case u v t and s
which are passed to the boundary
condition
and some some custom parameters that we
want to pass the function
in this case we know what the surface
temperature is this is passed through to
the to the boundary condition through
the model through this fields argument
and it's just a temperature a location i
j
and the k location is the top is the
surface so it's great dot and set
and our target temperature
temperature wanna restore our our
surface temperature too we're passing it
through through the parameters argument
so there's gonna be parameters
dot
click yes
now the flux i want to evaluate
is a restoring flux so we can pass it
through a restoring
parameter let's call it lambda
and then
our surface temperature minus our target
temperature
this function we can pass it directly to
the flux boundary condition will be
evaluated at each point at each time
um
we define it as giving it indices to the
function so we have two ways of defining
boundary condition we have continuous
boundary functions
which are depend on a position and
discrete boundary functions we depend
which depend on indices and this in this
case we since we have an array we passed
in indices so we have to tell this
to the
boundary condition that this is a
it is a function in a in a
discrete form
and then we can pass the parameters of
the
of
the function which in this case our ts
which is our surface temperature
lambda or restoring parameter which we
can put to 0.01
okay now we have
our surface boundary condition and we
have to put them in into the
boundary conditions of u v and t
and for this we have
a type called fields boundary condition
this type will
found this type will contain all the
boundary conditions of the of the field
so west east north top south and bottom
south
uh north south top and bottom an
immersed
position
and in this case we want to change only
a top bound condition
this is what we specified
okay let's run this
field boundary conditions
okay so uh a field boundary condition
will look something like this
so um our u boundary conditions are
default in all directions because we
didn't specify anything
and we actually change the top boundary
condition this is going to be a flux
that is specified by a query
and the same product temperature
everything is going to be
a default
so a default means that in periodic
direction you're going to have periodic
boundary conditions and on walls you're
going to have
zero flux
and we specified only the top boundary
condition which is a restoring function
with parameters which are our surface
temperature
and our restoring parameter
so now we have everything that we need
to specify our model we define the
physics we define the boundary condition
we defined our grid
and we can construct our model
it's going to be a static free surface
model
it's going to neglect the vertical
direction
um
because in the vertical direction
there's going to be only a balance
between the pressure force and the
buoyancy
we give it our grid
we give it
closures
boundary conditions
which are
me just collect them here
they have to be a name people
um
on
um
what am i missing i'm mixing the traces
and the buoyancy so i'm going to see
what
specified and the tracer since we have a
buoyancy that depends on temperature
salinity we have to
uh specify temperature salinity as
tracers so in this case we have a
temperature tracer and a cylinder tracer
this is all we need
to find
an ocean
it doesn't take too much to compile
we could also specify
different advection schemes or different
schemes for for the free surface
evolution but that i i kept everything
uh for default
uh this is just the basics that we
require to uh to have a notion up and
running
seems like it's taking a while to click
on bob
okay we have it
so this is our um
our model which runs on our gpu on an
immersed boundary grid
it's it has a um
add-ons batch for time stepper so at the
moment we only implemented that for
hydrostatic free surface model we cannot
use other
timestampers
it has temperature and salinity tracers
and these are our three closures that we
that we defined
uh the horizontal one it's explicitly
stepped
while the vertical ones are implicitly
that
we have our buoyancy
and
we are ready to uh to run this model
well before that we can we can set the
model with
some kind of
realistic key initial conditions
so that means we set the temperature to
something that can be the minimum
temperature in our ocean
and our salinity to a realistic value
okay
and now we can now we have a model we
can define a simulation
first of all we need a cancer
so uh the time step a realistic time
step in the ocean at this resolution is
something like 20 minutes
and if i want to write here minutes i
have to
use
the fancy ocean annikans
uh units module
so we run with a principle of 20 minutes
which is kind of realistic
and we run for
30 days
i can define accumulation
and let's hope that everything is
specified correctly
and let's run it actually no let's put a
progress first just to show where
where we are
so this function is going to be a
function that as greg showed we're going
to be calling a callback
um
to show our progress so let's say
time
is going to be
time
alteration
model the time is in the clock
object
uh let's print the maximum of the u
velocity
so
i've done our simulation
um
maximum of the absolute value
of our explanation
our velocity is in velocities
you
and let's print also the maximum
temperature
see how the temperature adapts to our
boundary conditions
temperatures in the creatures
uh objects
um okay
now we can we can put this
functional callback
let's
give it an interval of
time steps
and let's run the simulation
and see if
nothing crashes
oh shenanigans
it's a tough thing to spell yeah
[Music]
okay
if it runs i should have run it before
so
compiled but
let's see if it takes too much time
or not
okay initially fine
so we start with um
with a zero velocity field everywhere
because we didn't set the the u velocity
and with a field which is minus one in
temperature everywhere
uh salinity we actually give it a
constant
uh field and no boundary conditions so
we expect salinity to not change at all
while we expect temperature to increase
at the surface or and to match the
boundary condition and velocity to be
pushed
by by the winds
especially in the southern ocean and in
the atlantic ocean where the winds were
the strongest
okay
completed
so now it should be a little bit
faster
hopefully
okay
so our ocean is
simulating
uh
you can see that the last temperature is
adapting quite quickly to the to the
boundary condition the maximum of
temperature is about 32 degrees
so it's uh stopping quite quickly our
velocity is also reacting to the
boundary conditions so that's nice to
see
and the simulation is finished
so we just simulated 30 days of an ocean
we can look at
the output now what our model looks like
look at first uh
temperature field
here
let's look at the surface which is the
is the last
last point is 12.
here
okay so the
the temperature field has adapted quite
nicely to the boundary condition
so um we have a temperature which is
quite higher
at the equator and
lower the poles but if we look at it in
uh
another plane so let's now cut it in the
atlantic ocean
so this would be around 80.
that's how the interior of ocean looks
like
and we see that not much has happened in
the actual interior everything happened
near the surface at the moment we
probably have to run it for much more
than 30 days to see
something happening
um
we can also look at our
our velocity
let's look at our new velocity maybe
and the velocity field has uh is being
pushed around by the wind so we have
acceleration
eastward acceleration near the
near the
uh southern ocean and in the atlantic
and
uh
westward near the near the pacific ocean
so that's kind of what we expected
looking at the wind there is quite some
some noise here near the southern ocean
because
um we didn't really use
very good numerical methods so um
our direction as as gradual before also
our direction is
um
advection is is also center second order
so we probably would need a we know
are we not scheme to have this um
to have a better quality in our
in our solutions but yeah this is
basically the whole process of setting
up a realistic ocean
um and if you just throw resolution on
it you actually get very nice results
because um
chris can i show the the slides yeah uh
sorry i just need to
get back to this
yeah i'm just trying i'm sorry
i had it on full screen i'm just uh
coming out of full screen and it's going
slowly
i'll get there
so i think you have do you have the
slides here
i do i can i can
yeah so that's the one
yeah i'll get that there we go
uh okay
if you look at that that image
yeah you go to 112 degree below
yeah so this ocean that you see here
this is a much more result than what i
just did here
it's kind of
uh it's one two agree
so
it's 40 times the resolution of what i
have
but um but the methods are basically
those with nothing really changes much
here it's just is a slightly more
sophisticated advection scheme it runs
on more gpus
but uh all the all the methods that we
put in the models are exactly the same
so it would it doesn't take much maybe
like it was this hundred lines of code
and then you can have
a kind of realistic ocean with uh with
those shenanigans
excellent
so
i'm not sure we have many new questions
in pigeonhole and if you try this on on
on the cpu it's going to be
a little bit slower but uh it will run
and it will run
in a decent time span
so i'm just going to go to pigeonhole
but i think everything is still is quiet
there at the moment i think people are
just
uh
admiring the the ocean any questions
so um let's see i'll i'll just go
through and just check whether there's
any other ones that
um
so next up we were actually going to
start looking in some of the inners of
the code um and so
maybe we'll take
what do you think simone should we take
like a five minute break just uh yeah i
think so um pause for about how long
you're going
yeah two hours so it's a good time for
just a quick break and uh
yeah
simone in a building where the air
conditioning isn't great so it's kind of
hot at least in my office
glass of water
so maybe we'll take a five minute break
and we'll come back and um
because then
greg was also to sort of give an
overview of the code dive so we'll
hopefully we'll get him back shortly
um otherwise we can do it yeah
yeah yeah sure okay uh let me see if
i'll just
i'm going to see if i can put it we are
on a five minute break thing up
on a five minute
great get back so i said we'd just have
a five minute break briefly to go and
grab a glass of water or coffee or
anything like that that sounds good yeah
my computer just blinked i don't know
why that happened but okay yeah so i'm
just gonna grab some water and stuff and
then we'll get into looking at the code
um
you
you
hey simone you're back
yep
how's it going so there is a question
around
uh how to estimate where is it kind of
i've got on the screen so it's is there
a way to estimate up front
the resources needed for a given
simulation
so um
yeah so the the the one quarter of the
degree model so let's say
that is uh
how much is it
1440 by seven
so about a 40 million points grid fit on
12 gigabytes of memory
that's six yeah six hundred fourteen
fourteen
yeah so that is that fits in on on on
let's say 10 10 gigs
so of course if you if you want to add
diagnostics
so you want to add more fields then
you're gonna have to use more memory
uh you can have an estimate so this this
10 gigs are for
the velocity fields
and two
for five fields so let's say that one or
shenanigans field
on a 40 million
uh grid point
takes about
takes about two gigabytes
a little bit less also you should
clarify um
the the memory is allocated when we
build the model not only about the
simulation yeah yeah
yeah the
memory all the fields are contained in
the model
so you typically if you
you know another way is through trial
and error i often use that
wow
and
you just hold the model and if it runs
out of memory then you're you know
you know what your situation is
so for a realistic setup does it how
much does the immersed boundary take it
is it a 2d thing oh yeah it's it's
it's a 2d thing if you want to have more
complex bound numbers it's like
something that
some some uh so there can be 3d immerse
boundaries yeah
and that will take that will take a 3d
memory field yeah
wait just so grid fitted bottom is 2d
grid fitted laundry is 3d
most of the time we're using 2d though
yeah well you don't need caves then you
can use you can use 2d
only caves of bridges
anyhow okay so yeah so so it's mostly
those
five 3d fields yeah
right
um it's 15 right because there's two
tendency terms for each field oh yeah
okay let me now i have to edit my answer
i don't know how to do that
yeah the footprint is uh it's roughly um
the number of prognostic fields times
three
plus um the number of diagnostic fields
which
can range from i think
one
to as many as there are tracers so
um
depends on the um scenario being
simulated
so some turbulence closures allocate a
diagnostic field for every tracer
and you also have pressure
yeah so argell's asking a bit about some
of the numerical methods so for the
hydrostatic case i guess i'll
um the there are some implicit solvers
we use that involved but they are kind
of matrix-free and they're actually 2d
problems for the non-hydrostatic stuff
that greg was showing um there's either
one or two scratches
yeah for the so that's yours was using
an fft based over was it greg i forget
yeah that but that also uses one or two
scratchers yes that has a few scratch
arrays for that um
so it's typically it's because of the
complexity we don't i mean i personally
don't expend any effort trying to figure
out you know trying to calculate in
advance i mean i don't know there's no
problem
out of memory error is fine yeah you
know so i usually use trial and error
personally
and then you get some sense for the
particular setup you're doing like what
your boundary is
um
yeah
okay
so
we're two hours in so i think we'll get
through some of the code and probably
won't get to the last bit we were
imagined yeah um
so
um
so i think next up is you greg do you
want to share your screen or do you just
want me to page through the slides
um
i only have one slide for the overview
so how about you maybe i can just go to
that
you want to yeah a slideshow or no um if
i do that then i it messes up my other
stuff so let's just
okay so um
this next section uh we're
going to
uh dive
as they stay into the code
um
although as you can see there is
actually not a lot of code on this slide
so we're just going to try to describe
uh the inner workings of ocean against
and
how the the software you know how the
software is put together under the hood
um
so i'm to start i'm just going to give
an overview of the structure of
oceananigans and i've
titled the anatomy of an ocean model
so ocenanigans the way i think about it
is that it's essentially it's kind of a
right now it's a mono repo
for three distinct codes
um
and the two basic codes are the ones
that are at the bottom of this pyramid
so uh the first one um is an engine for
discrete finite volume calculus on
staggered grids
uh so that means that
um so we're doing
we're solving partial differential
equations so we need to have a way of
representing things like derivatives and
integrals
um and so for that we use a finite
volume method
and then in addition to that we're using
this method people call it a staggered
grid method where
some the the location of some of the
grids is staggered by half of a cell
with respect to the others
um
and so
if you don't know what that is um
you probably want to read about it to
learn more
because it's um
it can get sort of complicated under the
hood and so a lot of the abs a lot of
the features that we have are
um
are intended to help help deal with this
deal with doing calculations on a
staggered grid
and so this engine um
it involves some low-level features and
some high-level features that the users
see so all the stuff that
um
kind of regard as user facing isn't is
bolded on this slide
so one basic object one some of the
basic objects are the grids
um rectilinear grid and latitude
longitude grid
um another basic object is the field
object which can represent
one two or three dimensional fields
either
fields that either have um
data explicitly associated with them
memory associated with them or they can
a field can also represent
a computation or a value without
explicitly allocating the memory
associated with fields is an
infrastructure for
building abstract operations which
um
are that's a user-facing feature for
constructing
expression trees that represent
calculations on the staggered grid
so derivatives
um arithmetic
um et cetera and and also reductions
like
averaging maximum minimum et cetera
um chris you can't
you have to go back slide
you have a second screen or
no i'm sorry yeah no it's okay um
responding to questions
yeah
maybe i should share be sharing uh
that's fine carry on i went again i just
noticed that was a question for the next
one i'll share yeah we'll get it up
okay so uh
and then in addition to that user the
user facing abstract operations there's
also a
um
internal feature we call operators
which um is a method for it's it's this
it's it plays the same role as abstract
operations
but it's a little bit simpler and more
more performant and lower level
so it's another way to build expression
trees
that represent calculus computations
uh but at a lower level
um
that
and we use that to build
kernels that can be executed on the gpu
or cpu representing computations like
for example the right hand side of a
partial differential equation
and then finally i'm also lumping in
into this finite volume engine the
solvers that
solve elliptic problems on
oceanians grids and sometimes the
solvers have features that are specific
to oceanic and fields
so these are these solve i mean at the
end of the day i'm in a discrete system
it boils down to solving linear algebra
problems um sometimes we use ffts for
that
um sometimes we use matrix based methods
et cetera
okay so that's the
engine for finite volume calculations
now
there's another aspect of the code
which
has utilities for
running numerical experiments so
basically these are utilities for um
integrating a model forward in time
and and
and in this con in this context i'm
defining a model as con it's a
representation of the physics of the
problem and it also includes a time
stepper so these utilities for numerical
experiments are really they don't have
any physics in them they're just um
convenience convenience functionality
for
um
running loops over a time stepping
method
um that in
with data that's with functions
callbacks and output writers which
intermittently write data to disk or
execute some other um execute some other
task i'm also lumping into this the
field time series abstraction which is a
way which is a
convenient feature for analyzing output
um basically creating a time series of
fields
from from data that's generated by an
output writer
and then there's also a interface a
code-based interface um with that you
know if you are if you're writing a
model you have to define a couple of key
functions like a function that timesteps
the model forward and a function that
updates the diagnostics diagnostic state
of the model um in order for the model
to interface with the simulation
so those are the two
think of those as the two building
blocks
that oceanicans has implemented and then
um the models and right now we have
three models non-hydrostatic
model hydrostatic free surface model and
shallow water models those three models
are implemented on top of those building
blocks leveraging the finite volume
engine and leverage and interfacing with
the simulation
um for user convenience
and so the models what they do is they
implement uh
the numerical methods specific to
certain physics so like for example
coriolis forces
involve a stencil that's um specific to
models that have coriolis forces in them
and i'm also you know including
buoyancy models
turbulence closures and forcing
in that category
um and so so all of those all the
implementations of those types
are in this model code
uh
models also
implement
physics-specific equation templates so
the way that the way that an ocean
animations model typically works
is that
an equation with many terms
is coded up into a kernel and then the
user
the user um
toggles turns on it
toggles terms on and off or controls
their behavior with types like
a type representing coriolis forces or a
type representing the turbulence closure
and finally um in ocenanigans
models also need to define time-stepping
methods so we've spent a little bit of
effort in abstracting that but
i think the right way to think about it
now is that um every model has to
implement its own time stepping method
and that and that's because many of the
time stepping methods are specific to
the physics problem being solved and
they include specific
um
implicit explicit treatments of
different terms um
okay so that's the basic anatomy of
shenanigans um
and hopefully we'll have more models
implemented in the ocean and against
infrastructure eventually for example
sea ice
or compressed in the future or a
compressible model yeah
so
i'm just going to answer the question i
think we've probably covered them all
but let's go back just to see
uh i think we were that one's dealt with
um
yeah okay so i think next up we're
actually gonna
for
people who like to look at julia code
start looking kind of under the hood a
bit at
what's actually in these layers that
greg described so so many are you gonna
share am i gonna we're gonna add you
right now
i can show this so
um
yeah
i'm gonna talk a bit about the
operator's model module so uh this is
kind of our uh the backbone of our of
our engine it contains all the functions
that we need to do uh derivatives
differences
um also a little bit higher operators
such as laplacian
um higher order derivatives second third
and fourth and this is all physics
agnostic so it all
runs on a staggered grid
so the the
the backbone of these operators is that
we have
we have our values defined at faces or
centers
and these operators takes us from a
center to a face or vice versa so for
example if you have your values defined
at cells
centers you can derive it from the cell
centers to a cell face or if you have it
defined as cell faces you can derive it
from a subtitle center
and you can do the same thing with input
interpolations
so these these functions are actually
very simple um i can show you a bit how
the
prob is better if i show it here because
there's a bit of meta programming here
that makes it
slightly difficult
so
um can you go on with the slide
sure
let me go
do you want yes there yeah go there go
there there's a kind of example of
how our operators are are defined if you
go two slides after yeah i'm trying to
it's not moving hold on okay
anyways these are there you go there you
go these are very simple uh operations
uh they're all second order so our
differences here are second order our
interpolation of second order our
derivatives are second order
um but they're designed in a certain way
uh which is kind of um
it is an example of how shenanigans is
designed so uh they are first of all
they are local
so uh each one of these operators taking
a i j k n i j k index and are defined
for a point in in in your grid
um and they can be composable so um this
is what i show here in this example
so um we can we have we can have uh
several ways to define a fourth order
derivative
but a way the way which is done in our
shenanigans is done through building
blocks or um defining an abstract tree
so the first the most basic building
block is a difference
and you can see how it's defined here at
the top a difference of of a function is
just the function evaluator let's say
the difference in x it's just about the
function evaluated at a certain point
minus the the function evaluated uh
either a plus one or minus one in in the
x direction and this is a very simple
function but we can use that to define a
derivative
so a derivative in this case is defined
as the difference divided by a spacing
and we can we can start composing
functions in this way right so then the
second derivative is going to be nothing
but the derivative of the first
derivative
so we can pass the derivative as an
argument to the first derivative
function and this will give us a second
derivative and we can continue in in
this way to uh to build up the third
derivative so the third derivative is
nothing but the first derivative of a
second derivative which is a first
derivative of our first derivative and
so on to the to the fourth derivative
and in this way um
so for example if you look at this
fourth derivative stencil right it's
defined a point i j k
but it's it's actually if you if you
follow through all the code is actually
takes in a five point stencil
because it's a difference of a
difference or a difference of a
difference so in this way we didn't
really explicit explicit write a full
loop over stenson summed the whole
stencil but we composed the function
starting from very simple building
blocks
and this is the way the whole the whole
of ocean against kind of works
um everything everything which is not uh
global computation for which we need
actually solvers on this uh
chris we'll talk about later
is defined as a function of ijk
and if it can be constructed by simpler
function is always constructed as a trio
operations
so just to give an example
let's go to see a little bit of the code
go back
so um our tendency functions which are
quite complicated functions are
constructed in the same way so we have
for example
if we look at the
the tendency functions which calculate
the whole uh
um
divergence of of the diffusive flux the
divergence of the affected flux
function function
yeah
they are all pointwise operations so
this for example is the the divergence
of the effective flux barotropic
pressure gradient the coriolis force the
the divergence of the diffusive field
they all depend on ijk grid and if you
look at what goes inside here we're
going to have a difference of fluxes
these fluxes will be defined as whatever
closure you put into it but they're
always going to be defined point wise
starting from basic operators
and this roughly how we we specified the
whole we designed the whole the whole
code
and um this
has not only the advantage of the fact
that the code actually is a little bit
simpler because it always starts from
some simple basic blocks
which are the the operators
but um
it also has the advantage that we can in
the end we can wrap
these these local functions in
kernels which through the magic of
kernel abstraction which is a package
i'm going to talk about later
abstracts all the loop over the grid so
we don't have to usually uh codes up
loops over ijk
and then do the calculation but we don't
have that because um we specify all our
local functions and then we wrap it
around this thing called uh kernel
and this kernel comes from package
general abstraction
and um it's it's launched on a gpu or on
cpu now if it's launched on a gpu
um
the the the the kernel will actually
take the the cuda kernel structure so it
will launch it with certain amount of
threads and blocks and we'll calculate
the index and do the calculation locally
through the
individually for every column
and if you have a threaded system uh the
loop will be will be divided into the
threads if you have just one chord the
loop there's gonna be a loop but in
in this sense we don't have a formal for
loop we only have local calculations
that are wrapped around kernels
and this gives us simplicity in the code
and and
hopefully performance
yeah
right
can i ask a question because
sure
nobody asked it i thought somebody might
ask it but they haven't so i'm going to
ask it so um
do you want to explain a tiny bit how we
think about immerse boundaries in the
regard of the
operators like this and the magic of how
that sort of happens as well just it's
you know that's kind of clever too
most boundaries are
well immerse boundaries um actually
extend all these operators
um so if you have an immersed boundary
derivatives across our immerse
boundaries have to be zero uh
interpolation have to have to take care
that you have and immerse boundaries and
responders there so we extend all the
operators
we probably have will have a better way
to do it soon
but um
[Music]
we
all uh where was the conditional fluxes
and conditional derivatives
so all the operators if they are um if
they are specified on an immersed
boundary will will see if the the
the location of your grid is within or
without an immersed boundary
if uh if they are in a fluid domain they
will perform the operation that they
have to perform otherwise they if if the
if we have an inactive node then um the
operator will return a zero
that's just very simple way that we
implemented it so there's an if
condition
that wraps around the operator
thanks
so let me go back to my screen
yeah so i think we're going to get
oh can i remove it
hold on how do we do that uh yeah and uh
to finish a bit so
um this is not this is not gonna work
this whole wrapping around operators
local operators will not work if we have
a global computation so that is the case
if we have to uh solve an elliptic
equation
or uh
in that case
uh we have other techniques that we use
so we actually have some solvers that we
implemented and they will not follow
this pattern
uh also in in uh for for higher order we
have some higher order um
reconstructions that are in the
specifically in the advection module so
the election term we do it with higher
order methods
um and in that in that case we have to
specify
we have to specify the whole
reconstruction in one go we cannot
compose
second order interpolation so we have
other operators which are specified
specifically for advection in the
adventure module
okay
greg do you want me to show the abstract
operation slides now or i can i can
share okay go for it
okay so in addition to that uh
low level interface for building
expression trees we also have a
high level interface for building
expression trees that's user facing
that we call abstract operations
and i think
you could think of this as a it's a
language for building lazy
representations of these expression
trees
so
um
and it supports reductions so as an
example i'm showing you
computing something that sort of
resembles dissipation
called epsilon
and so this epsilon is the is
d by dx of u squared plus d by d y of v
squared
and so i've created a graphical
representation of what that looks on the
right
so you can think of an expression tree
is you know nodes
nodes connect like connected nodes right
so
plus is a binary operation that adds
two binary operations which themselves
are power
taking which they take the um
the derivative of u
to the power 2 and add that to the
derivative of y to the power 2. so
that's what the that's what it looks
like um graphically
and so when we when the and it's sort of
grayed out maybe
see if it
oh okay so oops
uh okay so i didn't have a it's
just so this is what
so when you you when you're using ocean
against and you create this kind of
object this is what you get um you get a
binary operation and it has um this sort
of text art
that represents the uh
the tree
um
and so this is potentially very powerful
although very complex
operations
sometimes don't compile on the gpu
but this is
this is the system that we provide so
rather than so many other ocean models
they'll hard code
um certain diagnostics and you select
from a very long list which diagnostics
you'd like to use but our philosophy is
slightly different so
instead of doing that where we provide
this language so that users can
construct their own diagnostics
and so that's the importance of the
abstract operations
[Music]
and
i guess if i wanted if i could make a
comment about
uh the code
which was supposed to be the point of
this section um i'd say that
this is basically a re-implementation
of bases broadcasting so it's very
similar to how broadcasting works it's
all based
around get index
extending get index for the different
operations
um
and the the wrinkle that we add is um we
uh so we have some infrastructure for
doing these calculations on a staggered
grid so we make sure that things are all
um
are sort of kosher and done correctly at
the correct locations
um given um how the
location of a field changes when you
take its derivative et cetera
um and then the final comment that i
wanted to make about abstract operations
is okay oh yeah so
the other wrinkle with abstract
operations is that
um so
in a simple case like in this case with
epsilon
epsilon can be evaluated at ijk at any
moment in time and it uses the data
that's currently in
the field u and v
but in the case that an abstract
operation so and so to do that we call
this we wrap the abstract operation in a
field so that allocates memory for it
and then we call compute on the
field in the case that an abstract some
node in the abstract operation itself
requires a global computation so that
would occur
if the abstract operation depended on an
average for example
um
that that means that we need to
pre-compute that node um if it hasn't
been computed in order for the abstract
operation to be correct so the way that
we do that um is so when we call compute
on an abstract operation like epsilon
it goes through and recursively calls
compute on every single node and so
in the case in this case we call compute
on every
on the
yeah on every node but
nothing happens because none of the
nodes require any significant
computation for this example
but if one of the nodes was something
like an average or a maximum or a
minimum or something like that
then that field would be computed prior
to evaluating the abstract operation so
that's
that's um that's how this
that's how this method works under the
hood and and there's also a feature
um
that attempts to it's a sort of a small
performance optimization um
that attempts to build some awareness of
when a field was computed so that if we
evaluate many abstract operations that
all depend on some
average or global computation that we
don't have to that we don't end up
re-computing
that average
if we don't need to
um so we sort of like cache the
the physical model time at which the
computation is done
and check that before recomputing
so that's that's abstract operations um
nice
so
did we want to have questions or
i think there's a there are a couple so
why don't we
i can bring up the
not sure they're directly related to
uh abstract operations but that's uh
that's okay um
one's about long wave simulations on
like going up shores and things do you
want to say something you love that
stuff greg
uh well
i don't know exactly what long wave rock
simulation is um
but i guess we don't support wetting and
drying so i'm not sure if that
matters but
um in order to you know if we wanted to
have a simulation in which a wave you
know
encroaches into previously dry land we'd
have to
have a way of representing wetting and
drying or
so so ocean indigenous can't do that
and probably
we probably won't well we might support
some simple wetting and drying but maybe
not the extreme kind of that would occur
in that
scenario i think that's much that's more
for a code that does like volume of
fluid method or something like that
when the the other question i think
uh it's interesting i guess uh
can you run more more than one
simulation in parallel while only having
one gpu so do you want to yeah yeah
that's fine
yeah we we do run on uh on a single gpu
more than one simulation
uh i'm not extremely sure if that is
that is recommended
because you're you're kind of uh
stealing the resources from one solution
to another so
i know that that modern modern gpus have
this feature of of parallelizing
the resources within the gpu itself
that's the 800 from nvidia i think
uh but you you would have to see what
how the gpu handles your simulation
because
there's no feature specifically we do it
all the time
yeah
yeah our ci runs we uh one of the
machines we have has one gpu and we run
up to 16 jobs on that one
so yeah but yeah
and what kind of
the resources your gpu has and how to
utilize them
yeah
so
there is also a feature in the code that
i'm not sure we're going to get time to
look at which is the one you use for
kind of ensemble runs here greg where
you can actually run
a bunch of independent
columns in a single mod which is kind of
like running lots and lots of different
simulations in parallel all within one
configuration
right yeah so if you want if you have it
on if you have a problem that requires
an ensemble of model runs
um
um and every member of the ensemble is
similar
and
every member of the ensemble has one
reduced dimension
um then we have actually we do have some
special features that are designed to
support that case um which are utilized
by the other this other package called
parameter estimotion
and if we get time at the end we might
get to that we'll see yeah
i just fit in a tiny bit
okay so i was going to talk a tiny bit
about
solvers next so solvers as we described
them earlier are the things we use for
non-local computations so everything
we've looked at so far is mostly local
stencils although greg mentioned
averages and things which obviously
extend and so on but there are places
where we need to solve
um
sets of equations that kind of go across
many grid points so that's what this
solver layer in the um kind of
organization of the code is about
and
in the oceanic context and just in the
kind of fluid problems we've looked at
so far um
two places where we're doing this we are
shown here so we kind of we've written
solvers
that are fairly general but they do
they're driven by what we need them for
so one is for
mixing in the vertical so along a single
column kind of um
handling a diffusion equation where the
diffusion gets very large and we don't
want to take a tiny
time step and one is for solving
a 2d or 3d pressure equation which is um
a place where in the navier-stokes
equations when you solve them
numerically
there are some pressure terms that
evolve in time that have very fast waves
relative to all the other dynamics in
the ocean and
we care more or in many situations we
care more about their kind of average
behavior than their
instantaneous behavior
and so we have the option to kind of
solve
with a much bigger time step by using an
implicit method for those
as it says here those solvers are mostly
general numerical generic numerical
implementations that could apply to
other domains as well they're not really
tied to the ocean
and some solvers also use external
libraries like qfft or fftw um the set
that we have at the moment in that
solver block of ocean and guns is very
much driven by what we need so
just to sort of make that a bit more
concrete this is kind of
a schematic of
the sorts of things the 1d
um implicit solver is used for
if you think of the convection example
greg was showing we were modeling warm
fluid rising explicitly when you do the
large scale ocean things that
simoni was showing sometimes we have
strong cooling at the surface and we
don't want to model all those little
plumes that greg showed they're kind of
we just want the aggregate effect of
that so
can you imagine this is my little
schematic of some surface cooling of a
column of ocean um
if you looked at that in the vertical
and plotted say temperature you'd find
that you had
cold water so theta is my temperature
variable here you might have cold water
overlying warmer water which makes it
kind of unstable it means that it should
have those little plumes that greg was
showing but we don't want to kind of
model that because that's
something maybe it's not not resolving
one of these large scale models so
mathematically what you can do is just
kind of say
okay i'm going to approximate the
behavior of this kind of
mixing process on the left here by a
diffusive problem
and just make the
diffusion
at the
in the areas where things are unstable
where you want to mix very large
and then
that if we tried to do this just using
the operators that
simone described
things would take a long time you'd have
to do many many small time steps so
instead we can then
formulate this essentially and this is
common in all the solvers we have to
where
we're stepping forward in time but we're
actually
um
stepping forward in time implicitly so
we end up with an equation
that has some operator on the state
we're looking for at time n plus one
equals some function in this case it's
just literally the state of the uh field
at time n so we're looking for the time
n plus one state but we have some
complicated function applied to it and
typically that you know has some wide
stencil so then you end up with these
non-local things so in this case
in the semi-discrete form you end up
with a tri-diagonal sole over
lots and lots of columns that are each
column looks like this say and then
they're spread out over the global ocean
um and so for that
we have
solvers def defined for problems like
that so this is an example of the
tri-diagonal solver we have that is
used for
this problem in particular and that one
it's called a batch triangle solver so
we we have a generic interface
solve
um that supports all of these implicit
methods that we i'll look at a couple of
them and then we specialize by
dispatching on a particular type for the
solvers
in this case
we are interested in something we've
coded up as a batch tri-diagonal solver
so that is
essentially saying you know we want to
do a triangle or solve but we want to do
it over many many grid columns all at
once so if we're on a gpu we don't just
want it doing like one column at a time
we need it to kind of um be able to do
all of them in parallel these are
independent souls
so
i've shown a little fragment of the code
of how we do this really you know from
the point of view looking at these high
level soul things the
key point in the code of you if you work
with these things is that for each of
our solvers we do it ultimately end up
with a function called solve with a
particular signature for the type um and
that those are that that signature is
somewhat generic but it's you know you
can kind of any any solver we want to
add to the code we would give it
it would have to supply its own soul
bang type method and so
um
in this case for the tri-diagonal solve
you know we
for anyone who's familiar with it you
have a kind of
upper middle and lower triangle bit and
t is again another example of uh around
the question of memory this is some
workspace the solver has some workspace
so if you actually
had a
code i think that was doing a
tri-diagonal solve
that would actually add a little bit of
memory to things when we when we create
this solver we pre-compute
um some of these terms i believe so
right greg i'm just going to check with
greg on that i think
we pre-compute these terms yeah
uh
those can be also functions
okay yeah well they could be fun
okay so it's only the workspace that
actually might need to be allocated yeah
actually we don't pre-compute them yeah
yeah but so you yeah but uh so but there
is a workspace i'm just trying to
remember what the workspace is workspace
is needed just then so it's adding one
array is that right the workspace t is a
workspace isn't it
ah that might be true yeah yeah
um
and so uh and this shows a little bit
just i thought it'd be fun to show here
kind of
how
these solvers then actually look in
terms of
interfacing to this the thing that maps
things onto
kernel abstractions and um i think
simone is going to show a bit more than
this a bit more of this later shortly
but essentially
similar to what simone was saying with
operators in this case
here we have
in the end of this and i'll show it in a
minute a function that has iterates
explicitly over the vertical index or
one index k
um
but the
kind of working over all the horizontal
indices is again implicit we don't
actually write down a loop for that
instead we kind of have this syntax of
saying
do this kernel over
all of these x y points and then
launch these kernels using this kernel
abstraction method
and that will
iterate over the horizontal here
so x and y are horizontal dimensions
and it'll do the same if you're doing
this on a cpu it would just you know
kind of cycle through it sequentially if
you're on a single core or if you're
doing it on a gpu it will actually
spread it out with blocks and um
uh
kind of the the uh abstractions gpus
have for
subdividing their domain so i think
i'll see if i can actually
leach a bit of code with this let's see
how it looks
so under the hood then you know what's
in a solver
um
is typically
not using it may be using the operators
as building blocks but it's got its own
kind of looping structure so i just
wanted to show that so
um here
you know we're actually explicitly kind
of looping in our own code um in the
solver because
the algorithm requires us to do that and
that's part of its kind of difference
between these local
operations and the global operations and
as we're saying the the coefficients can
actually be functions and so
um there's some
clever stuff that can go on depending on
kind of whether the grid is
even or stretched and that can all be
embedded in these coefficients to try
and optimize how this works
so the other sorts of solvers
so i just want to show a little bit
about the elliptic solvers we have
let's go down
so the the other family of solvers we
have is a set of solvers for solving
elliptic problems of this form where
you've got
del squared so d2 by dx square plus y
squared d2 by dy squared plus d2 by dz
squared and we have 2d and 3d forms of
this
plus a constant times or a sorry value
times some phi variable this value can
be zero in some equations but it's kind
of the general form we have solvers for
has uh allows for a value here equals
some right hand side um and we actually
have a number of solvers for that so we
have um
an fft based solver which is the one
that
greg was using in
the
convection example and
i'm not seeing the implicit there's a
you were using implicit free surface i
think where you're in cement in
uh
the
hydrostatic run but there's a different
2d horizontal one that i think simone
may have been using in the um
uh
hydrostatic run so
both of the all of these again export a
kind of soul bang interface and
have their own
types used to initialize them with the
appropriate kind of
data structures that go with the
different methods each method is can be
quite different
so the family of methods
i think we've added a multi-grid
recently as well so i think i did this
before multigrid appeared which was only
like a day or two ago
is at the moment in our solvers is we
have
um
a
batch tri-diagonal solver for these 1d
problems in the vertical
and then a number of different solver
options that have different numerical
properties and are appropriate for
different situations
um that solve these elliptic problems of
this form so
in particular the
for instance the fft based boss and
silver
is very very fast but only works for a
very regular grid
and then for things where you have say
immerse boundary con conditions and
other things like that and you're on the
sphere then we use things like these
preconditioned contribute gradient
solvers
um
so
i think
given what time it is i'm going to
actually skip
the hands-on bit with that i think um
it's it's linked in the
notes but um
just so that we can get through the
other bits of the sort of parallelism
and other parts of the code um
i did i do want to show this just you
know if you're interested in kind of
learning about the solvers and their
interfaces
then again there's
you can look at the interface the
um
documentation online the help stuff by
doing what greg did in the repo there's
also that's all in the
you know the same information is in the
kind of in the api reference that goes
with the
code so
if my computer wasn't too slow yeah here
we go so let me just make my font
maybe a bit bigger
so for each solver
we have
you know some
documentation that describes essentially
how to how to instantiate create a
version of that solver
and then how to apply it um
so the kind of creation of a solver is
quite different for each one so if
you're in a batch tridiagonal
solver then you know you have to pass in
your
lower diagonal
diagonal upper diagonal
operators or
functions
or values
if you're using the fft based solver
then really there's you know there
aren't many free parameters for the fft
solver because it really only applies
for a
totally regular grid so there's not much
and it really only solves one one set of
equations um
but then there's um the iterative
solvers that do these elliptic problems
like the
um
a five diagonal iterative solver has
a number of options around tolerances
and
preconditioner options and
kind of um the sorts of things you might
expect for a an implicit solver and um
so if you're creating one of these
solvers you have to actually kind of
uh figure out or you know allocate the
appropriate data structures for
configuring them in the right way but
then once you use them they kind of
mostly all you just use this or they use
this solve interface in a quite similar
way
and i think that's yeah so i think that
was it for
uh maybe we'll just
link to pigeonhole see if we've got any
more questions
on pigeonhole i'm not sure if it
refreshes let me just try refreshing and
see
okay so then i think we're on
to
some money you're gonna you want to say
a little bit about you know so there's
an important piece to this that
everything can also run in parallel so
are you gonna do you wanna do it from
your screen or how do you want to do it
i'm gonna i'm gonna share the screen
when yeah go for it i'll just say a
couple of things and shut the screen so
i think i'm just gonna show some
demonstration because it's a little bit
quicker we don't have time so
um
so um can you go back to the slides in a
second oh sorry yeah
just to say a little bit because we have
two different paradigms we have
um we as we already said we use kernel
abstractions which is this great package
to allow us to to run loops on on the
gpu as cuda kernels or threaded loops on
on the cpu
um and i mean we we didn't come up with
this package we were just using it but
it gives us this great opera this great
ability to to abstract away the the the
parallelization on the gpu on the cpu
and i can show quickly like how how you
define a kernel
um
just
um you can define a kernel with a with
an external
macro
and we can define it as a function which
adds
uh
to uh to an array
one let's say
and um the index of um
the index will be calculated directly in
the in the kernel function so we can
just define
we can just
grab the index so this index will be
will be grabbed from the from the kernel
um through the classical thread index
dot x or uh block index definition if
it's a gpu or it's gonna be grabbed by
the by the threaded loop or by the loop
on the cpu so it's all abstracted in
kernel abstractions you can go check
that package out if you want to know a
little bit more this is just to show how
it works so um we already have directly
the index from in this function
and now we can just add
we can just add
one to our square array
and this is our uh how we define all the
kernels in uh you know shenanigans we
just have a kernel which wraps around
um
a local operation
and
um
if we want to if we're not called this
we can call this um
this function with
an architecture
in this in this case i want to i want to
run this on a gpu so i'm just going to
give it
a um this type which which tells me to
run it on gpu and then we need a work
group and a work size
so if you're a little bit familiar with
how huda works
uh this basically tells you uh if a kuda
kernel how many threads and how many
blocks you're using
um and will adapt to to uh two threaded
loop and on a cpu but here it's this the
second argument is the total size of of
the array empathy or the total size of
the loop i want to do so 10 in i j and k
and this is the the amount of threads
per block that we're using in this case
um and once we define this um
this function we can just run it so we
can create um
in this case a q array
of zeros
and we give it our
our size
so we have we have a
we have a vectorable depends on the gpu
and then we can just
we can just run our our
our loop function that we defined as add
with a certain work group on our certain
work size we can just run it with our
arguments
and this will return us an event because
this function is is actually calculus is
asynchronous
by default so it returns an event
and once we run it we can just wait on
the
event and whatever has happened
is our we have some one to our x
uh array so it's just as simple as that
um we and i recommend you to to check
out canon abstractions to see a little
bit more how the innards of this uh
parallelization works
um
so this is we we outsource it through
current abstractions but then we have
some more coarse
coarse-grained polarization
so let me go to
we have an mpi
uh typologization which is a little bit
more classical so just multiple
instruction multiple data
um
[Music]
we just have our where
[Music]
we have a distributed model which
extends basically all our methods
um and the mpi depends on a multi
architecture the smooth architecture
will have inside all the information
about the ranks that you have and the
connectivity between between your ranks
and uh through this connectivity we're
gonna we're gonna fill the halos in our
usual mpi uh send and receive operation
and this is
uh using the npr.jl module
but
um
we just have
uh
it's a little bit meta programming here
but some uh i send i don't know if it's
visible
i send and i receive functions so
everything is run locally except for the
for one we need to fill the halos of a
different of the different ranks
um
[Music]
to handle um
global soldiers which are quite a pain
because
they cannot be run independently for
each rank
we have we use pencil fft.gl
which is a great package for
for our
for our fft solver
this is actually pencil ffts does the
whole uh transpose and fft routine so
you can imagine that we that we
discretize our whole grid in pencils or
slabs so across the x either
uh the x or the y or the x and y
direction
and um
pencil as a pencil of the routine will
will transpose the our our data in such
a way that one directional time will be
will be local perform the fft and then
transpose in the other directions
perform delta t such that we have all
the
all our our data transposed
transformed in the
wavelength domain
then we can perform our derivative and
come back to the spatial domain
and this is all implemented through
pencil fft now recently greg has
implemented a way to do
um
fft uh to do
um
a global solve with stretch direction so
in that case you don't you cannot do an
fft in the structure stretch direction
but you have to do a diagonal solve
so that requires doing transposes
uh two transposes with an fft you uh you
expose the local direction where you
have a vertical stretching you do it you
solve a true diagonal system
and then you go back
uh in the transpose and and transform
back to the spatial domain
so here's our strategy for
um distributed memory and at the moment
this only works on cpus we have no
implementation of uh fft on the on the
gpu for distributed grid because we
would need to implement qft but there
are plans to put qfft in um
in pencil ffts so that we can just
dispatch that in case of a
gpu distribute multi-gpu distributed
system
something that we have a little bit new
is uh is a multi-region implementation
this is a way
to um
to have a single single node multiple
device uh computation
so basically our um it if you go one
slid might slide after chris
uh we're on your slides but
yeah i think whose screen are we it's
not my screen anymore i think it's
pranks
that's a great screen okay okay wait let
me do this
okay here we are
so um this multi-region module actually
was born because we needed a way to do
um
more unstructured domains so we need a
way to have uh individual domains are
rotated one with respect to each other
uh so we came over we came up with a
with an abstraction to to have
independent domains
and then we we we figured out a way to
actually
um allocate these in the on different
gpus
um so
this will uh this all holds on on the
concept of a multi-region grid
you can you can partition a multi-region
grid in different ways and allocate the
memory in different on different devices
so i can i can show a quick example here
maybe i can can run what
what is shown there
so
let's say we define we define a grid
you already have it there
why am i using those shenanigans
but
i was using kernel abstractions
unfortunately so we can um we can define
a grid on the gpu and then we can this
this grid is going to be defined on the
device that i have on right now
which is
uh device 0. this this system actually
has
has four devices that i'm running on
so it has device zero one two one three
um now i can i can take this grid that i
defined on on with z on
zero and i can split it
partition it into different devices
so this this is done by defining a
multi-region grid
of our grid we can choose a direction to
partition it in in this case i'm going
to partition the direction that has
has eight points
so i'm just going to define two
partitions in the x direction
and i'm going to define on which devices
i want the memory to be allocated
and this is going to be the files
devices zero and one
so now i have create
a leaping grid
which is allocated on two different
devices
um
and the bits i can actually define a
module a model
so this will create a model which has
the memory allocated on the by zero on
device one
and we we defined a different uh
an abstraction for loops over devices
that works
that works and kind of in the same way
that kernel abstraction works for for
instance
so when you run a kernel you abstract
the loop over the indices and what
multi-region does is abstract abstracts
the loop over devices so if you have a
local computation
um you can you can wrap it around
a macro that is called that it's called
just apply originally and that macro
will take your function and split it
into into the different devices that in
which your memories are located if you
have memory located on different devices
and this is a way to have
um
sorry
no
this is a way to have your your um
an easy way to have a multi-device
system and this is thanks to the thanks
most
jl that has
all these new advances in switching
devices and copying memory
asynchronously between one and another
device
um but it allows you to have one ripple
open
and
have memory located on different devices
i control the model now it's taking a
while because it has to pre-compile
and to have a model which looks exactly
like your normal model but runs on runs
on different devices
um
and so the the only change that you have
to do
in the code
is to uh
well this compiles
can you go up
uh yes sure let me uh it's gonna show
how this achieved in the code because
this is taking a while to pre-compile is
that one yeah it's this one so uh if you
see we have we have some local
computations
and some global computations
um the only thing that we have to do is
just to append this apply originally in
front of local computations and that
will if if any argument of the function
there is a multi-region argument so it
is recognized by our shenanigans to be
allocated on multiple devices
uh ocean against the applied originally
will perform a loop
and and apply
locally this function to each device
of course for global computation we have
to do something different
because we cannot apply a global solver
regionally
this is kind of
a region of research where
we're struggling a bit into because
uh having multi-device
global solvers on a gpu is quite
difficult so
at the moment
for the ultrastatic model we have
an implicit solar that is running on one
gpu
so our global solve is gathering all the
data from all the other gpus is
performing implicit so that's capturing
back the data
but for this we probably want to have
uh ways to do this in a more performant
way in the future
and we also have plans to merge the mpi
distributed and the muta region
paradigm to have some more of a unified
parallelization
environment
that is mostly
how parallelization is done in our code
nice
okay i don't know if there are
any questions
just before the clock runs out i'll just
say thank you everybody for joining and
of course you know it's everything is
open source what we're doing so we
always welcome prs and
uh there's a happy ocean logan's channel
on julius lang so you know anyone wants
to join he's been on this who hasn't
joined already feel free yeah
i know anything else greg on that just
i think slack is
if you want to chat dead on slack
okay let's just see if there are any
last questions so uh
can you provide the color retraction
example to get up i'm sure we can yeah
we can put that somewhere
um
and i think that maybe
it's a reload just check
great workshop there you go oh well
that's good that's good to know so um
yeah if you come back
to the workshop next year we'll be able
to do something on parameter estimation
here
but i think
we're done for this
exactly yeah we'll have way more
together so okay so i'm going to hit the
end broadcast thing so bye
thanks everyone
and if you want to contribute get in
touch